we won't see the big nintendo switch
presentation until january but that
doesn't mean we haven't heard some more
details I'm Tony and this is your
promising gamespot news update nintendo
president tatsumi kimishima talked
briefly about the consoles price and
launch lineup saying the company isn't
planning on selling the switch at a loss
for reference the we launched it 250
bucks and the Wii U launched at 300 in
terms of games the only confirmed launch
title is legend of zelda breath of the
wild but the switch trailer did give us
glimpses of splatoon mario kart 8 NBA 2k
17 and skyrim remastered kimishima said
the launch lineup will appeal to people
across many demographics so getting a
variety of games like what was shown in
the trailer makes sense the nintendo
switch presentation is slated for
january 12th we'll hear about the
release date price launch lineup and
specs when that day comes to stay up to
date with everything Nintendo in the
meantime you're already in the right
place